okay
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this meeting of baylor district
council's cabinet
and uh it does feel a bit strange so
we'll be back here finally after 15
months
and although we're all in the same room
you do seem a lot further away than when
you're on the screen in front of me
first i want to welcome council mccraw
to cabinet and
welcome alistair to your first cabinet
meeting and
i hope you'll enjoy the afternoon
so um may i remind all of you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons in the
chamber
and in the social areas please ensure
that you wear a mask unless you are
speaking or if you're unable to do so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please maintain social distancing at all
times during the meeting
and during any breaks please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and additionally we will be using
everting as usual for this meeting on
the modern.gov app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
until the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
and i'd like to move to the agenda now
please but first um
agenda item nine which is paper bca213
the gateway to home choice allocations
policy
review and amendments is going to be
moved up the agenda
and it will now be presented before
agenda item 8
which is the court for performance
presentation and also in your gender
pack item 16
is listed as a confidential item it is
not a confidential item we'll be
addressing that
at um item 11. so
those are two sequence changes to the
order of proceedings
um so firstly um item one apologies for
absence
thank you and uh moving on item two to
receive declarations or pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
are there any to declare anyone
nope thank you
item three and that's paper bca21-1
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the baby cabinet held on the
11th of march
and you'll find those starting on page
nine of your agenda pack
so if i can move through those um page
nine if anyone has any comments or
questions
page ten
page 11 page 12
page 13
page 14.
page 15
page 16
page 17.
page 18
page 19
page 20 and finally
page 21. okay
no questions no comments
okay i'd like therefore to um
have a proposal please for those minutes
happy to propose chair uh council holt
and council malvisi second
governor's office can we conduct the
vote now please
thank you chair members if you could go
to the plus sign in the top right hand
corner of your mod.gov app
and select voting the vote for this item
is now in progress
so
thank you chair that's eight votes for
that's unanimous thank you
moving on then item four to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
nom received chair thank you item five
questions by councillors
non-received chair item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint order and standards
committees there were none
thank you moving on then to item 7 the
forthcoming decisions list
which you'll all have seen prior to the
meeting does anyone have any comments
on the forthcoming decisions list
no okay
thank you for that so we'll move on to
the next item
which is item nine that has been moved
up the agenda that's paper bca
21 3 gateway to home choice allocations
policy review
and comments i'll now ask the cabinet
member for housing to introduce this
report
council osborne yep thank you mr
chairman
i am delighted to present to you today
paper mca stroke
21 stroke 3 gateway to home choice
allocations policy review
and amendments the paper before you
today sets out some proposed changes to
the allocations policy which is used to
assess applications
for social housing and allocate vacant
homes
the changes are predominantly related to
national legislative or policy changes
therefore to ensure compliance with our
statutory framework these changes are
recommended
in december 2020 the ministry for
housing communities and local government
issued new code of guidance called
allocation of accommodation
guidance for local authorities this
clarifies
new ill eligibility accommodate
criteria for european applicants
following on
from brexit this guidance has also been
considered while developing
and updating the allocations policy the
list of changes are set out in appendix
b
but they include disregarding local
connection criteria for spouses
and civil partners who are required to
leave accommodation provided by the
ministry of defence
following a breakdown in their
relationship with their service spouse
or partner clarification on how
properties in rural parts of the gateway
may be restricted so that only
applicants with a specific type of local
connection
are eligible for allocation of these
properties
clarification that when completing
financial assessments on households to
ascertain
whether they can meet their own housing
need will now include
all adult members of the household not
just the main applicant's income
the cost of the amendments to the it
system totals 4500 which is split
equally between the seven local
authority partners
therefore there will be a one-off
revenue cost of 642 pounds and 86 pence
for each council in
2122. if we fail to make the required
legislative changes to the allocation
policy
then we could be in breach of our
statutory duties
under part five of the housing act 1996
as amended
therefore the changes proposed ensure we
meet all
relevant legislative and policy
obligations
if the council continues without the
proposed policy amendments
it remains at risk of a challenge
these changes are essential now to
ensure we comply with the legislative
changes that have come
into effect the gateway to home choice
project board
want to conduct a wider review of the
allocation policy
but this is a significant piece of work
and will involve consulting with
applicants
and members fully which naturally will
take time
if we fail to make the changes proposed
today and wait for the wider review to
be completed
we are at risk of legal challenge as
just stated
the wider review of the allocations
policy is now commencing and will take
place
including consultation over the next 12
months
i'm pleased to say an equality impact
assessment has been carefully considered
and has attached an appendix c to this
report
i would like to propose the
recommendation set out in 3.1 of the
report
as set out in the appendix a of this
report myself
and the corporate manager heather are
happy to take any questions thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor osborne may i have
a second to please
councillor malvisi okay then cabinet
members
does anyone have any questions at this
stage before we move into debate
no okay
um we have one other member of the
council president uh
council mclaren do you have any
questions
no chair okay thank you right
um if there are no questions um we'll
move in
uh straight into debate then does anyone
wish to
open this with some comments about this
paper
counselor holt yeah my question really
is um
in considering this review and what
we've got in front of us
are you happy that um this policy will
now be fit for purpose in that
local residents will possibly be higher
up
in the allocation process because a lot
of complaints that i've come across
since being a councillor
is that people who live very local to
housing especially new housing
seem to be jumped by people from away
out of the district
and further afield so i mean are the
real issues being
addressed in this review so that we can
ensure that the people
in our wards are actually getting the
housing that they need
councillor osborne can you respond to
that because it is it is um
a concern obviously and i know you're
aware of that that um
we want to make sure that as far as
possible that um
local camin local with with some
allocations yeah
um yeah thank you mr chairman this is as
i said in my
introduction it is only a review to
ensure that we're compliance with the
new legislative changes that have come
into force
um again as stated there will be a more
robust review
later on in the year i know that a lot
of members have mentioned to me their
concerns about the current allocations
policy
and that's when all those concerns will
be looked at within
within the wider review and we're
fortunate that we actually have our
corporate manager actually is the
chairman of the board of partners now
for
for gateway so i'm confident that she
will bring forward that review
within the 12 to 18 months that we
specified in our introduction
but yeah i can assure you those concerns
will be looked at councillor holt
within the wider review
thank you thank you councillor osborne
and and uh
to be fair there is an additional
paragraph in there that does strengthen
that um
local connection for um uh certainly for
rural housing
are there any other questions sorry any
other comments that people would
counsel busby just to follow up on that
just
sorry when was that when are we going to
get the information from the review
you said 12 months in your thing but
then you said later this year
is there a 12 month review starting now
or we part way through it or
um no it's it's commencing now as i
mentioned it the review is now underway
yeah it would i i will say it would have
happened sooner but
i'm not using it as an excuse but with
kovid it was because of other priorities
that took place
and rightly so it took a little bit of a
back seat but it is now coming forward
because i know its members
have mentioned it quite for some quite
years now that they want this review so
no it is
currently starting to take place
thank you council mccraw
i just wondered in para
for sorry i'm going back to the original
paper there's a mention of specific
examples where a local connection
uh is takes greater priority
in rural locations and i just wondered
if there were some examples of those
specific circumstances
thank you and so the clarification in
the policies just to make
it clearer we get a lot of queries
around the local needs properties that
have advertised
um and it's not necessarily as clear as
it could be in the policy at the moment
so it's about changing the word in
but the reality is the allocations
policy can't determine which properties
are designated for like a village
connection that's set through the
planning system
so when a section 106 is greed as part
of planning permission it's at that
stage it's decided whether or not
it will be a connection to a particular
village and then cascade in parishes
or whether it will be a district-wide
connection and the allocations policy
then just ensures that we comply with
that section 106 agreement
but at the moment it's not as clear in
the policies it could be so that's why i
want to make this initial change just to
make it a bit clearer to hopefully
reduce the number of queries we get
thank you heather can i follow up on
that chairman yes
i'm presuming the review will be looking
to establish even greater degrees of
clarity
in that area because i think it is an
area where there is a lack of clarity
because
the circumstances can vary so greatly
between one planning permission and
another
and of course existing housing and you
never people are never quite certain
particularly also with housing
associations and agreements that have
been made with those it is a very
mixed up system in some ways and we need
to provide
a better understanding for the people
applying
i think they do find it confusing
hey council i've got councillor davis
and then councillor holt
yeah thank you if you wanted an example
um
in in my ward in ganges ward we were
able to get together
the housing team and the planning
officers and and obviously we had a
recognized local need
and so this was for our housing and and
its work is almost completely completed
in september
and certainly a small percentage of
those are dedicated to
those with very local needs and then the
rest cascade out depending on their
banding and everything so
you know i've got a lot of people
knocking on literally knocking on my
door saying when they're going to be
finished we want to move in
but it can work but the system i think
is appreciated needs to be tightened so
that we can have that
greater control um in those areas
but there's so far working together with
planning and the housing team
has brought good results for us that's
it
yeah i think derek's sort of know what i
was going to say really i think is the
consultation with the planning team
that needs to begin early on these on
these projects so that
we can ensure that when it comes to
planning they have the appropriate
uh conditions attached to allow that
allocation process to really cut in
and benefit the local people who really
we feel i think as war members they
deserve
to have those properties are made
available to them so thank you
yeah i certainly think that would aid in
clarification so that
people are fully aware of what what
properties available and who
who's um
allowed or at least eligible for for
those properties
um i just want to pick up on on one
other thing
and and i think it's going to be a
question for you heather um or
and that's regarding the um improving
the actual access
to uh social housing for victims of
domestic abuse which uh it's good that's
been strengthened but one one thing that
uh i think that
we we probably don't um
cater for that well is if if somebody
has to move out of district
uh as a result of that if if they're
housed in a refuge in a neighboring
district
or provided with some sort of a
temporary or emergency accommodation in
the neighboring district
that that person then becomes the
responsibility of that district
for further housing
whereas there may well be specific
family ties
children still in in baby and the
individual might wish to return
how do we provide
reassurance that that that return to
baber is is something that we'll be able
to support with housing
thank you council award um in regards to
domestic abuse
somebody can actually present to any
local authority in the country so they
will make an
informed decision about where they wish
to move to um
if somebody wants to remain living in
the district then we have to carry out a
risk assessment to ascertain actually
the risk
posed to them and the risk of pursuit
and whether or not it is actually safe
for them to remain and if so
what safety measures can be put in place
to prevent any harm coming to them
so we're not we don't exclude anyone
that's the victim of domestic abuse from
remaining in the district but we have to
make sure it's safe and
appropriate for them to do so before we
we do house them
yeah so there is um examples where there
is domestic abuse but there's also
um but they still have shared um
arrangements in regards to children and
so
often um independent independent
domestic violence advisors or social
care will advise on
the safe methods of how children can be
handed over it's often done for a third
party
and so the perpetrator won't necessarily
know where the person's moved to
thank you for that does anyone else have
any further comments to make about this
counselor
it's just a quick one for heather
probably um and it's
it's as a result of the talk about um
local connection
there's a a difficult balance that you
have to strike isn't that between
the need the requirement and the
connection
because um i don't know if i'm the only
one i'm sure i'm not
um i get emails from people who've got a
local connection but they haven't been
allocated one of the houses because
an assessment has to be made of what
their accommodation requirement is
so we're not going to put a single
person in a three better um
and also there's the balance that you
have to have with regard to need
and we can learn something from that
because
when we're providing these homes
we need to have a a good assessment of
what the local need is
what type of property otherwise we could
be building homes for local people but
there
aren't actually the local people with
that accommodation requirement
thank you class of that rfe um yes so as
part of allocations policy when
for example a rural exception site where
the criteria is that somebody's got to
be allocated
who either lives in the village or um
normally is like then cascading parishes
around there and then thirdly will be
like a district-wide connection
um it's prioritized by the first being
being who's in the village and actually
what band they're in
so those in highest need that live in
the village will will qualify first
and it will then cascade further down so
it'll look at band a right through to
band e
then it will look at who lives in a
neighboring parish and then who has that
district-wide connection
but i mean sometimes we do find that
actually those that have the local
connection are adequately housed
so actually when it is a rural exception
site often those housed in those
properties will actually be adequately
housed for example in
private rental accommodation in the
village at the moment whereas we've got
a significant number of people on the
housing register
in a much higher need and a much higher
band but because they haven't got that
local connection they don't actually
qualify for it
thank you does anyone else have any
further comments they wish to make um it
seems that the
these these changes are
they've covered quite a number of areas
which um i think
did need um further clarification and
strengthening so
as as um as a review of the policy as it
stands i think um
what we've got here is is is very good
very useful and so
um i think i know council osborne
you're very happy with it aren't you
yeah absolutely and um also look forward
to
the the more wider review as well coming
forward so but no i'm i'm more than
happy with the changes that have been
made to date
yep okay and we'll look forward to that
wider review so i think now
we can move to the vote please
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress on your modgov app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous
great thank you very much right we'll
move back now to item eight on the
report paper bca21
to the quarter four performance
presentation um
and i'll now ask the cabinet member for
customers
the new cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
to provide an introduction council
mccraw please
thank you chair um the
quarter four performances are before you
in the format that we've been using
the course of the last year i don't know
that i can add a great deal
to the information that's presented
there obviously there are going to be
some
particular points that can be picked out
on and i imagine that would come up in
questioning
if there are any questions uh sarah
wilcock would be here to answer
specific answers while i get to grips
with this new portfolio
so i i'll leave it there thank you
thank you counselor okay so sarah ready
for presenting
thank you thank you council award and
councillor mcgraw
so i'd like you to introduce our quarter
four performance presentation covering
the period january through to the
end of march 2021 you'll see that this
presentation
as council macro notes follows our new
style which was introduced at the
beginning of the financial year
and is focused on our six key priorities
from the corporate plan as well as the
overall health of the organisation
taken in its entirety the report seeks
to provide that high level assurance
that the council is delivering against
the corporate plan highlighting some key
performance measures
progress against objectives and a look
forward to planned activity in the next
quarter
i think it's important context just to
recall that whilst we've been enjoying
the benefits of the relaxation of
certain kovid rules more recently and we
look forward with some optimism for
further easing of restrictions
this presentation does cover an
unprecedented period
where we were in the throes of a third
lockdown and where we had to undertake a
re-evaluation
of projects and priorities to ensure
that as an organisation we could
continue to meet
challenges of the additional work and
pressures as a result of kovid
as is customary i don't intend to run
through the entirety of both
presentations
although i would like to just mention a
couple of things the first of which is
our desire to ensure that we continue to
improve the format of the
presentation making sure we include
engaging contact
content and with this in mind you'll see
that the third page of the presentation
provides an update
on the fantastic news that we are one of
the finalists for the iec prestigious
award for council of the year
we're also finalists in two other
categories including customer focus for
the fantastic work
undertaken by the planning enforcement
team and
asset management and regeneration for
the innovative virtual high street
project
a short video is embedded with
presentation which showcases some of the
amazing work that has been undertaken
across the council during this very
challenging 14 months
we've also built in a couple of case
studies that hopefully illustrate the
successful outcomes
and tangible positive differences we are
making to residents in our districts
through the work of central suffolk
lettings and through our housing
assistance policy
following feedback from quarter three we
have also reduced the number of pages as
well as reducing the amount of narrative
to try and make the the presentation
more concise
and also taking account of feedback from
last quarter
following today's presentation we will
circulate links to the um
presentation both in the council of
fortnightly email update
as well as the parish newsletter update
provided to all councillors and working
together for all staff
and counsellors i am particularly
conscious that we've now seen a whole
yearly cycle of this particular format
for the quarterly presentations but
recognise there is still more that we
can do
following the work we've been doing on
the stock take revisiting the strategic
priorities
there are a number of common themes that
have been highlighted which i will want
to work on over the coming new financial
year
this will include reviewing the
objectives ensuring that we are
drawing out the cross-cutting
initiatives more explicitly
and reviewing some of the key
performance measures and indicators we
use
and it's likely that any significant
changes will be effective from quarter
two at the earliest of this new
financial year
so that's all i wanted to say with
respect to the presentation
happy to hand back to the chair for any
comments and questions
thank you thank you sarah um
obviously this report is for noting only
but does anyone have any
questions on on the content or any
comments on it
counselor arthi um yeah i've got a
question it's a topic that um two years
ago was um
something we were quite concerned about
and it's to do
with um the wait time for a call
and the abandoned calls right
um so i'm actually looking at the um
diagram on page 26.
so it looks as though
there's an increase in the number of
calls
21 increase and we think that might be
because of
inquiries about council tax bills going
out
and that's given as one of the reasons
i think for the one minute 52 second
wait
time on average that's average wait time
of one minute 52 seconds
it doesn't actually say at the bottom of
that though whether that's an increase
or a decrease but i'm guessing because
of the text that's actually an increase
in the average
call time and we've also got
an increase to 12 percent in the
abandoned calls rates i mean that's
presumably people who've
waited for a lot longer than the average
of one minute 52 seconds and finally got
fed up and hung up
so this is something that a couple of
years ago we said that we
had to concentrate on and i think we
quoted a lot of
people in business who expect six
rings and the phone should be answered
and i don't know how many rings are in
two minutes but it's a hell of a lot
so i just wondered whether there's
anything more that we can do
to try and improve that performance
thank you council arthi uh yes and and
indeed i recall
um sitting in front of yourselves uh
talking about performance back in 2017
when i when i first joined and
average call rates were were well above
uh three minutes at some points and
abandonment rates was
were significantly higher we've
obviously done a lot of work in that
intervening period to
to bring those cool weights down and the
abandonment rates down
just to provide some reassurance the um
the statistics and the data that you can
see there is a genuine consequence of
increased demand
during that quarter four particularly
and that is because we see
a tremendous increase in the volume of
calls and
prior to that quarter we would see
averages of perhaps 300
a day during quarter four particularly
when we issue the council tax bills that
obviously go to all
residents across both districts we can
see up to 900 calls a day
and that's obviously you know on some
occasions nearly doubling
the number of days and we don't have the
capacity that we can double the number
of
members of staff within the contact
centre to take those calls
what we do do is mitigate the the um the
demand by making sure that the bills
have lots of information on them that
hopefully try and answer some of the
questions
and we also do have an increase in
members of staff who come and work for
us during that period to try and deal
with the additional
demand colleagues who have previously
worked in the contact centre who are
otherwise employed
in different jobs we get back onto the
comment to help us with our most
busy times and what i would say as well
is that if we look at the entire year
our abandonment rate is below our
average
for that particular period and below our
target so nine percent for the whole of
the financial year
and our average wait time for the whole
year was one minute 16 seconds
so again within our target and obviously
lower than
the quarter four performance so it's
something that we
we absolutely take seriously and we want
to reduce
as much of the the demand that comes in
and answer the calls as quickly as
possible
but um realistically the fact that we we
see those peaks
at that particular point in time which
are generated by council tax demands
also housing rent letters that are sent
during that period
and increases in the number of calls we
get around election time as well
will undoubtedly have an impact on on
the numbers that come in
i think okay can i come back on that um
if we actually know
that there are periods um that are going
to result in higher core volumes
you mentioned election periods and
council tax bills going out
um in in your professional opinion
is there anything that we could actually
do is is it a resource issue i mean
for a man in the street it's just
another person in the call center who
can share answering
the phone type of thing i'm sure it's
not as simple as that
but is there something that we can do
because it just seems to me that if
if it was a response time of 30 seconds
to a minute or something that's not too
bad
but two or three minutes and bearing in
mind this is an average so there may
well be
people i tend to be one of these people
um
who if i'm asked to wait i don't hang up
because i think my turn is about to come
so i keep holding on
and i did it funnily enough calling um
the council when we were in hadley and i
i waited for 12 minutes by which time i
was actually in the offices so there was
no point in apologizing to the officer
that i was late for a meeting because i
was actually there
so i presume that in these averages
there are some
quite high figures where people might
hang on and hang on and hang on they
might be hanging on the phone for five
or six minutes
thank you yes indeed there will be some
you know as averages work there will be
a number of people who
have waited longer than that average but
there'll also be quite a
high proportion of those people who have
weighted significantly
less and as we saw throughout the period
um
in earlier quarters most of our calls
were answered within about 30 seconds if
you looked at the
the actual number of callers rather than
the average
it does come down to resources and as i
say we do plan
ahead and try and secure additional
resource
at our most busiest times but with the
great
greatest will in the world when it comes
to a monday morning at nine o'clock
we'd have to have a significant number
of people to be able to answer those
phones to be able to deal with that
demand at that particular time
so our focus is about ensuring that we
try and mitigate
the demand that comes in so making sure
that information is clear and accessible
when it's sent out
we've also obviously introduced the chat
bots as well to
try and take demand away albeit that's
only for certain services at the moment
but something that we will look to
explore to
to roll out over other services as well
and i think as well it's a reflection on
the fact that
you know during this period of time lots
more people were at home
and perhaps paying a bit more attention
to
correspondence that they received um
through
through the council tax bills for
example and we think that that counts
for some of the demand as well
thanks for that probably a good time to
welcome councilman mccraw to his
portfolio isn't it
castle mccrory did you want to say
something sarah has already covered
one of the points because councillor
arthur did make the very
reasonable point is there anything that
can be done the chat box function is a
step in that direction to do something
right it is only being launched in this
quarter
and specifically covering the
environmental matters
but the aim is to extend that and
it's in the bottom right hand corner of
the front page of the website as you
scan down the page it moves to that
bottom right hand corner it's always
there it looks like a little
round robot face um
it's worth having a look uh at least for
the environmental portfolio
and so on um and i think it might be
worth considering
because these are quarter four figures
um it might be worth the considering
presenting some annualized figures
with the quarter four figures because
obviously that will provide a context
for for the entire year and that is
something i think we can maybe look at
in future presentations
but i'll have discussions with officers
on that
thank you council council holt and then
councillor davis
just following what alastair said really
i think if we had something to look back
over the past 18 months um not not
necessarily in this report necessarily
but
if perhaps it could be brought to
cabinet in a briefing just so that we
understand it better with that longevity
so 18 months might be an idea to give us
a good idea
how we progressed or not as the case may
be um
i would answer what's your ambition here
from one minute 52 you want to get it
down to a minute
um and you want five percent abandonment
what would you
consider i appreciate that it's been a
success to date and it's coming down
but where would you anticipate having a
baseline to say that i think we've done
really really well to get to that point
and we can't go any lower
thank you councillor hulk ultimately
we'd like to be able to
to be able to answer the phone as as
soon as anybody
contacts us so as as low as a a number
that we can
get to would be obviously our aspiration
accepting that
of course people do want to contact us
by by telephone and we're not going to
be able to shift
demand entirely away from our telephony
services and nor would we want to
and so i think as much as averages are
you know a useful indicator it's also
important for us to think about the
resolution
the resolution that we provide as well
so
certainly our ethos within our customer
strategy is about being able to answer
the call in its entirety
and sometimes that might take longer and
what i don't want to do is drive
behaviors within our
within our staff whereby we're just
trying to get through the calls as
quickly as possible
because we've got somebody waiting so i
think where we have it is about right
at the moment um with uh accepting that
you know 10 of people might um might
choose to abandon their call
and that's not necessarily because
they've waited over a minute and a half
they might decide that
30 seconds is too much for them to wait
so i think
what we have at the moment is is
reasonable and a good reflection
albeit we always try to improve upon
that
thank you sarah uh councilman crow and
then
castle davis i can just give a specific
answer to targets the target is set at
145
um i'm looking at last year's figures
just taking two quarters from last year
quarter three saw a response time of one
minute 16
seconds or actually that might be 1.16
but i suspect it's 16 seconds
and uh the following quarter 4 was 136
so under the 145
so we know it's possible to achieve just
over a minute
if that's possible it may be possible to
get closer to a minute
thank you councillor davis yeah thanks i
understand was quicker than i was in
finding the results
um but i remember in 2017 uh
working with sarah and and it was an
ambition to get under two minutes at
that time
so i think it's a reflection of the good
work that
she and her team have done and lee has
done as the portfolio holder before
to bring them down as they were last
year and of course the
this year is a little bit different for
a lot of us in a lot of ways
the only thing that um i'm still a bit
surprised at
knowing how much work has gone in and i
think the chat box is brilliant and i
think that's going to really really help
as it grows
and other departments is that the number
of calls compared to the number of
emails because
i know you've always strived to get
people to not pick up the phone and to
use other methods
the website the email and everything
like that so do you think there's
there's something more that can be done
to tweak on that as well as the chat box
thank you councillor davis yes
absolutely i think
there's still lots of work that we need
to do particularly around our website
and making that much more intuitive and
easily
navigation um is improved on there
that's some of the feedback
that we receive from our customers
directly is that they find it difficult
to find things on our website
and that is part of our customer
transformation program to look at that
to to make improvements so absolutely i
think there is more that can be done
to see decreases and we have seen a
decrease in our telephony contact if we
look at year on year
we have seen a slight decrease in this
year
and i think that's part and parcel of
people going to the um to the website
more
and we've seen increases in the email
traffic as well so
i think there's a general trend there
but what we'd like to do is make sure
that
all of our channels are really easily
accessible and particularly our website
is very
clear and people can find information on
them
readily
okay um if nobody from else from the
cabinet has anything they want to ask i
know
customer mclaren you wanted to ask a
question
thank you joe sarah
in this report
i'm very pleased to see about the
digital skills training
unfortunately on the peninsula
which is where my ward is um
there's very little um support in terms
of the libraries i mean it goes to
shortly that's it
and i was wondering how you're going to
address this problem because a lot of my
residents
are not very good digitally at all and i
do want them to be
enabled if you like and empowered
to participate in in what is now routine
um communication with the council so
many of them can't do that
what plans do you have in place or
ideas i'd certainly like to be involved
in them
i brought this up before a previous
meeting
but i want to see you know some
moving forward of that because libraries
are doing a good job i understand that
but there's a big gap there thank you
thank you councillor mclaren absolutely
one of the
key areas that we recognize is the
importance of
digital inclusion to all of our our
residents
and within our customer transformation
programme we do have a specific project
that is all around all about in
making sure people have better digital
connectivity as well as
improving confidence around their their
skills and access
and we are working with suffolk
libraries particularly
on some projects to ensure that people
can access
laptops and ipads for example
and can borrow those readily but also
that's just
part of the issue it's about making sure
that actually they've got the confidence
and the skills to be out to be able to
to do things on online with confidence
as
we perhaps do so we do have some
programs of work that we are working
with other providers
that i'd be happy to share some further
information uh with you
and with other counsellors in the in the
coming weeks and months
and that will um that will be
specifically aimed at raising digital
skills across the whole of the
um of the two districts so
thank you chair thank you right
well if there is anything else that
anyone wants to say i
just wanted to wrap up by saying uh the
certainly the format um
we're getting used to this new format
now and it is excellent because it is
um highlighting very easily um
where where we've um areas where
things need to still need further focus
and we've had quite a lot of chat around
the um
uh the customers portfolio but um uh
clearly it also shows
um quite clearly where we've done very
well and there's
some examples um further on um
the response to flyer tipping 99 of fly
tipping uh cleared up
so very quickly um the the performance
of the uh
within the economy portfolio uh
particularly around the the
distribution of um kobe grants has been
absolutely excellent and all of this
data is so easy and so readily visible
here
um and uh i
certainly for for me the uh this format
is is excellent and does stimulate
debate very quickly and very easily
council of asperger you want to quickly
come in and say something yeah sorry i
thought you were just talking about the
customers to start with but if we're
going to go on to environment you
mentioned fly tipping
and there's a only 99 is a very good
rate um but it's
it would be better if it was 160
incidents of fly tipping were then
sorted out and people were charged for
fly-tipping
do we know how many of those 160 did
result in a
a court appearance or a fine or anything
like that
well we do have prosecutions and we do
publicize them when when
when they happen and indeed um there was
one last year that did result in a
six-month prison term so um
uh we as and when we can um
identify the perpetrators we we will do
and we do
prosecute and are successful in those
prosecutions but it is identification
obviously um
uh it does take um fairly forensic
analysis of of the rubbish that's left
and
and there's not always stuff there that
identifies the the perpetrator but um
we we do prosecute when when we can
and um and go for it hard i do
appreciate that it's just how many have
we done
it may not always be a prosecution it
may be somebody turning up and
writing a stiff letter something yeah
and um i don't probably have to get you
those numbers
afterwards i don't think any of us have
that
information to my idea
something i'd be happy to talk to
cassandra about and get some further
information
okay um thanks oh castlevania
you've got bottles and you leave them
beside the bottle bank
that's fly tipping
it's a process of education because
unfortunately flight tipping by
definition is fly
and what we need to get hold of are the
unscrupulous waste collectors who
collect the tires
from various places and then dump them
down a country lane
sometimes we can actually
find evidence of who they are but very
mostly we don't which is why we have to
have this massive campaign
thank you chair and also of course
it's incumbent upon anyone who hires a
private contractor to
take away rubbish to um to make sure
that um
they are a legitimate contractor and
they're going to dispose of it
responsibly rather than just take it
around the corner and dump it
um because the the responsibility is
is still with the um the the original
owner of the rubbish as well as
whoever took it away absolutely um and
it comes back to education people don't
realize that if they're the waste
producer
they have a legal responsibility to
ensure that they hand that waste
to a fully licensed waste handler
and that it goes to a properly licensed
waste site
council i think there's more ignorance
in education i think most people that do
this are fairly well educated they're
just ignorant to the point and just do
not want to pay
councilman crawl there's a fly tipping
reporting tool is the number
which has just been announced and it's
available for use on a mobile phone and
you can upload
the photograph and the location and send
it indirect
similar to the scc highways reporting
too but i hope for a little bit quicker
and i think also it uses what three
words as uh location so um that's easy
for anyone to yes that's that's
the system i believe but even so you
it's still you know you can map the
location you can
take a picture and if the information is
key
another thing of course is if the
general public become more aware of this
there's a better chance
of catching any of the people carrying
it out
and that's i think going to be crucial
okay everyone um well thanks for that uh
as i stated that
this item's for noting um before we move
on to the next item we are going to take
a two-minute break
um while we can move things around a bit
so if we can pause the youtube
transmission for a couple of minutes
my
okay welcome back everyone um and we'll
move on to
the next item on the agenda which
is paper uh
i'll back up my agenda further down
it's item 10 which is paper bca
2141 the sill expenditure program for
june
2021 and i'll invite the cabinet member
for planning
to introduce this report so counselor
alfie
thank you chairman um yes you will
all be familiar with the format for
the still expenditure program reports
this one contains an update on progress
on decisions
um in bid rounds one to six which you'll
be familiar with because we always give
you
the information going back to the start
of the implementation of
of seal you've also got
in the list emerging projects for future
consideration which are currently
developing there are two decisions
um for you today um they are
firstly the the bid for holbrook high
school
which is an increase in capacity from
590
to 600 pupils the cost of the bid
is 237 237
750 pounds from the local infrastructure
fund
and that's out of a total project cost
of 292
110 so there's a balancing capital
contribution from the county council
there of
54 360 pounds
the project is to increase the capacity
uh at holbrook academy from 590 to 600
secondary age pupils and this is an
additional education provision
which will be achieved through the
reconfiguration of the existing science
lab facilities
and with part of the science hub being
relocated
to the caretakers bungalow i'm not quite
sure what the caretaker thinks of that
but
that's that's the proposal the the need
for the additional secondary age people
places
is derived from committed growth uh
within within the area
that's principally stutton and chelman
distant where a total of
72 additional dwellings have been
approved
so the project will deliver
infrastructure needed in terms of
secondary school places
and that's in line with with those
granted permissions
the project is the the first pupil place
extension of a school
um using cell funds in baber although
you're probably aware of the fact
that mid-suffolk um have have had some
um so uh the
the amount of seal budget is fixed at
the cost per pupil
place so that's contained in government
guidance
from the department for education and as
the total cost of the project exceeds
this figure
as i said suffolk county council have
contributed
from their budget to make up the
difference to the total project cost
of 292 000.
it's classed as essential infrastructure
within the infrastructure delivery plan
and this project involving the creation
of ten additional places
is part of the overall expansion of the
school
contained within the infrastructure
funding statement used to be called our
infrastructure list
for for the council consultation has
been carried out with
holbrook parish council and the ward
member and the county councillor this is
in line with the provisions of our
sil framework their summarized responses
are
parish council they wanted an extension
of time to consider the seal bid
a small extension was granted but as far
as i'm aware
no response was received the ward member
is mary mclaren who had no objection to
the bid
and the county councillor simon harley
gave
full support to the bid
there's a little bit more that i wanted
to say about
this um because i'm aware that
some members may recall um that there
were
some fairly localized views about the
loss of the shared leisure facilities
at the school so
this is to do with abbycroft and and the
council
following following this a meeting took
place
between our offices suffolk county
council education officers
and the the headmaster issues about the
education need for the school
arising from new housing development at
stockton and charming distance as i
mentioned
that was discussed along with the loss
of the shared leisure facilities at the
school
and the impact on the community
and also the allocation of students
attending the school
from outside the peninsula
you've probably heard um over the past
few months comments regarding the fact
that there are quite a few students
busting
from out of district um but i
i will say that we are firstly not the
department of education
so we we don't fix the figures for
student places
nor do we run the holbrook school
and nor do we determine its intake or
manage its facilities
so we do have with us today joe fellowes
from the county council um schools
infrastructure program manager i think
but i'm afraid
i've only really tweeted just recently
who joe is because she keeps looking at
me
so joe and if there are any specific
questions about
um the the county council's need for
these places perhaps you can ask her
about the cost of the places
um and i'm sure she'll also be able to
answer questions about how children are
bused in from out of what used to be
called a catchment area or in this case
even from outside of
district the second bid
is at preston mary and it's a village
hall extension
to provide improved kitchen facilities
and
indoor toilets the cost of the bid is
109
000 pounds and that's from the local
infrastructure
fund the total cost of the project here
is 196
086 pounds um with other funds being
sought from other sources
um by the paris council or probably by
the village hall committee actually
those of you that were here in 2018 19
will probably remember this bid
and those of you with eagle eyes
probably spotted in the report in
the summary of bits around one to six um
i think it's on page
one four seven i think um
bid reference b0718 uh was
was the original bid for preston st mary
village hall
it's um it's to provide kitchen
facilities
and indoor toilets the village hall
is um is an ex-church of england school
and um had two outdoor toilets one for
boys and one for girls
and although they've been updated a
little bit
they still have outdoor toilets
and the kitchen facilities are best
described as a large cupboard
so the two things that they're in most
need of is indoor toilets and
proper kitchen facilities the village
hall in
common with a lot of small villages the
village hall is the social hub
of the village and the project will
enable
much needed improvements which will
increase the use
of the expanded facilities and there is
evidence of wide community support
for the proposal and the project is is
ready to go
with a new planning permission granted
in 2020
i will just mention the previous
bid and what happened this was
previously approved in the spring of
2019 i think at the last cabinet meeting
um before the elections uh there are a
number of
of different circumstances that have
have conspired
um to to leading to i suppose a lack of
commencement
um there was covered last year um there
was an issue with the planning consent
um there was probably a tiny little bit
of um
i don't know tardiness in getting the
project
off the ground i suppose um and then
when covid hit
i guess they started to panic so um
the um the funding was was reserved
which is is what we do
that was 130 091 pounds
and because that bit off elapsed
that money has effectively come back to
us
so the um the framework has changed
slightly you'll remember that we used to
allow
up to 100 in bids now we have
put a 75 000 pound and 75
limit on community infrastructure bids
this is this is one so um the previous
2019 bid was for a hundred percent
funding
um and to enable the project to now
proceed the village hall committee and
presence of mary
um have secured several different forms
of funding
to contribute and the amount requested
from the sale funds is now
109 000 pounds so the amount that
they're seeking from us
has reduced um and represents now 64
of um of the total project cost
so it comes in well under 75
however it is still above 75 000 pounds
so were we to be looking at this
with a clean sheet of paper now i think
we would be encouraging them to seek
even further funding from elsewhere
because of our new
limits in our sil framework however what
i'm asking you today
is that given that it's below 75
and given that it represents a saving
from the offer that we've made to them
before
that you approve the 109 000
which will enable the project to to
finally go ahead
um so on that one the consultation has
been carried out with presidents of mary
parish council who are wholly supportive
um the warden county councillor robert
lindsay
i was the ward councillor um for baber
up until 2019
and offered my full support to the
scheme appeared at cabinet to speak on
it as you may remember
um and robert lindsay was a county
councillor at the time and offered his
full support
we should really have had an additional
response from robert who's now the
district councillor and the county
councillor for president mary
um i reminded him of that yesterday and
he's emailed through
to the infrastructure team and to myself
two emails actually one offering full
support as the county councillor and the
other one offering full support
as the district councillor so once again
i'm proposing
approval so that's paragraph
three 3.1 and 3.2
and they'll ask for a second thank you
jen
thank you council arthur may i have a
second to please councillor osborne
okay members of the cabinet we've got um
these
two items um one i guess
is probably going to uh require more
discussion than the other but if we can
start with
questions before we actually move into
debate on on the the relative merits of
these
so to open questions counselor davis you
have a question
together all two or two separate
because there are two separate syllabids
we can take i'm happy to take them
separately if that's
if everyone's yeah we'll take them
separately
okay um are there any questions
counselor busby
the christensen mary bid and i ask how
much
sill presidents of mary village have
collected for themselves
can i just access that on the seal page
answer the question in about a minute is
that okay yes that one uh
happy for that go we'll wait for that
one and does anyone else have a question
at this stage councillor davis
um it'll take councillor arty a while i
think so
ask ask your question
i'm not sure who thank you i'm not sure
who i'm addressing it to
um but i want more details probably joe
about the
um about the holbrook bid in terms of
who's actually going to be using it what
sort of community benefit it will bring
um and why it's there the the caretaker
one i'm not well i think it's sort of
lumped in but the science block mainly
did you want me just to start with an
answer well you start catholic
just to point out i mean councillor
davis did mention the benefit to the
community
just to remember this is not a community
bid this is an education bid
okay yep uh i understand that council i
think
joe would you like to respond thank you
yeah
so um in terms of what accommodation
we're providing at the moment the school
only has four
practical science labs with the increase
of pupils they really need five labs
so what we'll be doing is um
refurbishing and remodeling the
accommodation
to provide that fifth um practical
science lab
and the space that that takes up is an
area that they call
the hub which is the sort of one-to-one
support
so that facility will then go into the
vacated
caretakers bungalow which is then being
refurbished to provide
those spaces so in terms of just
touching back on the community benefit
um
the only scope really is for the science
labs
to be used by the feeder primary schools
which is something that the head is keen
um that that they would come in and use
those
but um in terms of extended use of the
community facilities they're not really
appropriate for that use
particularly in the caretakers bungalow
because they're sort of one-to-one
support spaces which would have you know
potentially sensitive material
in them
i would have to check back off the top
of my head
um i do have some that he's named if you
wouldn't mind just giving me a moment to
look i guess i do have some that he's
named specifically
if you wouldn't mind if i just but there
are 23 feeder schools to
hold its academy isn't it it's not high
schools
okay one of the issues
well again this is a question what is
the percentage
of the people that are from outside um
if you like the catchment area
compared to those on the peninsula okay
so
out of catchment peoples there is
currently
um about 250 out of catchment pupils
but this extension of 10 places is very
much
for the developments that have occurred
within the catchment area within stutter
and chalmer distant
so through the planning responses we've
responded to say that these additional
places will be needed for in-catchment
children
and that is what we're building the
capacity in for
wouldn't it be fair to say if the people
weren't coming from felix don't leave
the market
the the school would be more than large
enough to accommodate the new people
that come into the peninsula and and
future growth as well it would and if
the school if more pupils come in then
it would potentially push new people
pupils coming from out of catchment back
to their their local schools but because
there has been historically
a lot of capacity in the school it's
drawn parents in
from other areas and that has actually
helped to kind of sustain the school
um over the last few years i mean it's
grown from 480
to 586 in the last three years so
those peoples have actually helped to
sustain that school during that period
really and and give it that sort of
critical mass
but it's fair to say that if
as more development comes forward and
more there's more demand within
catchment
it would then limit the amount of places
that were available for our catchment
pupils to come in
and are the county council able to
control that in terms of
we we don't control the admissions for
holbrook academy because they're an
academy they control that themselves
so the academy can just carry on adding
more and more
people from felix though indeed and
market clayton theoretically they could
but they want to be a school that caters
for
the need from the community so it
wouldn't it wouldn't really benefit them
to do that i don't think
i know you know this school quite well
but and you would you describe the
entrance to the
cabinet in terms of traffic or just any
entrance to the
road not walking around the back yeah
yeah it's um
it is fairly constrained but i think for
this
limited number of additional pupils
which are within catchment
we don't really see that that would um
sort of exacerbate any existing issues
that are there
i think if the school needed to expand
further that would be something that
we'd need to evaluate on its own merits
but
for this expansion we don't think that
it's actually going to
be cause any further issues in that
entrance area
but this would take it to 600 and as you
said there's
nearly 300 250 more coming from outside
and you'll be aware of the traffic
issues
and the complaints and this will just
exacerbate that won't it
it would but that's not what this bid is
addressing and if we were to
look at a further expansion there as we
do with all our other schools we would
undertake you know an assessment of
where those peoples are coming from
how they would be traveling and whether
there's any upgrade that is required
to make that in to make entrances safe
so
um that may be needed but that's not
something that's considered within this
bid because we don't think it's required
for the
for the 10 additional cases okay so this
takes up to 600 but in the jlp
it could be that the school expands to
800.
um do you really believe that's feasible
given the school the constraints it has
it could be
but it's just important to know that
those discussions need to be had with
with the leadership team at the school
and the trustees
and those detailed discussions haven't
happened so theoretically
it could but those discussions about
whether the school would
would want to accommodate those
additional pupils have yet to be had
can i just clarify because it is an
academy and it is
a trust what relation the county council
has with the trust
a good working relationship yeah i mean
legally because some academies don't
have any um dealings with the lea do
they
well we still maintain the
responsibility to provide sufficient
places
but in terms of the running of the
school they're not they're not an la
maintain school they access
their maintenance funding direct from
the dfe so there isn't that
that kind of relationship that there
would be with a maintained school
so you don't control salaries or
anything like that
okay and one final question sorry is uh
just
how do the county council in general
square off their um environmental policy
in terms of i'm sorry i think somebody
else wants to answer that i i'll step
back i've spoken enough right but thank
you very much for your help
thank you yeah thanks castle dave so i i
think we were probably
veering off the uh the focus of this
particular
um sill bid here um and um
yeah obviously we know about uh the
proposals for the growth of the academy
um there are uh the infrastructure
delivery plan has
i think 10 local site allocations which
could deliver up to
170 dwellings which will account for
that
expansion over the course of the next 15
years or so
in the lifetime of the joint local plan
but um we need to focus on
on this particular bid here and and the
purpose of the bid
and and uh the reasons for it so um
uh other do you want to come back on
council yeah i'll just just
search for councillor busby i'm sure he
could have done it himself but never
mind
um so the the shield pages indicate
for preston mary um a total potential
um seal contribution of 126
398 pounds and 94 p
that potential contribution is coming
from a development which
council busby sits on committee i'm not
sure if it went to committee this one
but it's a development opposite the
village hall
which oddly enough is also contributing
a new car park
well a car park for the village hall
um so 126 398 pounds and 94 p
i'm guessing that what you were getting
at was how much
sill is coming in from preston st mary
if 109
000 is going out um and the answer is
a bit more than we would be awarding
them today
thank you council marty just one final
comment from me on the
holbrook um i think we'll arrange a
briefing on on academies
it's probably probably a good idea if
all members
understood better that the how academies
work um
in conjunction with the county council
admissions policies etc
um and and and how that will affect us
uh
in terms of the uh uh planning authority
and and the uh
authority with um still funding but uh
yeah okay yeah and then council busby i
think wants to come back
okay i mean i can understand where
councillor davis is coming from but i
think
you've got to look at what the flip side
of that argument might be
and that might be that the new houses
are built on the peninsula and the
children
that are in those houses are going to
come to councillor davis and they're
going to say how come my children
can't go to holbrook and it's no good
just saying oh well that's because a
load of guys from felixstowe are going
there
the point is we have to plan forward and
the seal contributions are to provide
the funding to provide the
infrastructure
if you go back to the the old days of
section 106
these details wouldn't be in front of us
for discussion because
there would have been a 106 contribution
sought from the developer it would have
been handed over to the education
um authority as an education provision
and
we wouldn't have any idea where it's
going so
i mean in a way where we're sort of
lucky that we've got the purse strings
but i don't think we should get too
wrapped up
in trying to do the department of
education jobs or
joe's job or trying to sort out some
deal
with regard to the shared use of the
facilities there
this is about school places and it's
about money that's being contributed by
developers who are building houses
on the peninsula where children will
need a school
place thank you councillor
uh councillor busby you wanted to come
back on
that failure answer yeah don't
necessarily agree with that at all don't
we
um can i just ask how much is the
academy contributing towards this
the academy is not contributing because
they don't have the responsibility to
provide the school places
in terms of maintaining the buildings
that's their responsibility but
providing the places remains our
responsibility
okay and how do they get their revenue
is it by so much for child
yes yeah so that's okay so we spend the
money to
build up the number of kids that can go
there and they increase their
revenue because of our spend their their
funding agreement with the dfe would
change as a result of this so it would
increase from 590 to 600
and that's that's standard and whether
they're an academy or whether they're
maintained that they're funded for the
number of children
but the reason that we pay is because we
are responsible for providing those
places so we get
basic need funding from government and
we get obviously developer contributions
and other sources of funding but it's
our responsibility
to make sure that those place we've got
the funding to put those places in
the physical places okay i mean i
kind of agree with clive and kind of
agree with john that we this is probably
not part of the discussion for
for this facile and we ought to have a
session on
on the education but it's bonkers where
we're having 250 children being busting
how do they get there i mean the
strands like a car park most most of the
morning
so how do the 250 kids get there and
if we do have a development at shopley
we're going to have to tell them that
they can't use a local school they're
going to have to go to somewhere like
felix though
i mean the world's gone nuts we're
supposed to be cutting emissions
how are we going to do that when we've
got half the world's
parents ferrying children around the
councils no i understand you're
concerned there councillor busby but um
we are veering off the the subject at
hand here in this particular syllabid
the the the pupils in or the future
pupils
on the shopping peninsula will have uh
will will be provided for and
and um as as i said earlier the
infrastructure delivery plan
um shows how that provision will be uh
provided at holbrook so
but that would be the um the focus of
future syllabids
over the next over the forthcoming years
so we're just looking at this one at the
moment
uh councilman crawl i'm
it was answering the question you've
just said we're not talking about this
anymore so i will
i'll withdraw my thought
thank you all right does anyone else
have any questions
on um this
council davis you know
that we need that they need to expand i
know they want to and i think it'd be
nice or they think it would be nice and
we paid for it and the council
and the county pay for it but what
evidence is there because
from what i can see there is no evidence
that they need to expand they just want
to do it because of
higher pupil premium you know if if they
didn't keep recruiting from
outside the catchment area there
wouldn't be any need to extend that so
the question is what evidence is there
chairman i've got to say this it's not a
school application
it's a it's an education authority
application it's a county council who
have to provide the schools
to meet the growth to meet the growth in
the population
so i'm not quite sure that leveling the
question that the school itself
is is is the proper way to do it
we have of course got joe here who can
answer from from the county council's
point of view but to be fair i think
she's already done that
so the the current school or number on
role is 586.
and through our people forecasting we've
estimated that 12
up to 12 pupils will arise from the
three developments that were mentioned
so therefore that feeds into our people
forecast now they've been approved
and so therefore we think the additional
places will be needed to take the school
up to 600
and that that's that's how the people
forecasting works
need to increase the school capacity
if you were only carried on with people
from the shortly perpendicular or the
immediate vicinity of the school
but those children are already in the
school aren't they so enough
it could be a year for example there'll
be a change in september
you know can and we need this education
totally agree
you know the uh someone the education
say
you can only take from within the
catchment area and then you can expand
outwards but within the
numbers you've got already i don't see
the need to expand that's why i'm asking
what evidence there is for it
for there for there to be rather than
the desire to have both
our evidence is through the people
forecasts and that's what we use to
determine where places are required
so that that's all i can offer really
the evidence is based on what
40 coming from out of catchment yeah and
out of catchment feeds into those people
forecast not just
you know across across the county that's
how it's
now excuse me you've answered my
questions
after we can't really um discuss uh
debate admissions policy at the
academy we um uh we'll we'll pick that
up
another time and we'll get a better
understanding of that but
i mean there's a positive way of looking
at this
council davis that we have on the
peninsula
a high school an academy which is
proving to be very popular
um throughout the whole of south east
suffolk so um
okay uh castle holt you you had your
hand up
yeah i think um we've taken this as far
as we can take it i think that i cannot
sense the frustration with
two members behind me but we're dealing
with the policies that are in place and
and we've just got to learn to live with
that at the moment
if we do have a briefing on academies i
think we could all learn a lot more
but um i think the officers explained
fully
the reasoning behind it and i think
we've just got to go with that for now
and um if there's any amendments we'd
like
or opinions would like to express we can
do that at a briefing
um but i think i'm certainly in favor of
this so
i'm not quite sure where we were whether
it was a
approved or what or whether there was a
proposal or second
or wherever we are has it been seconded
yeah uh council council osborne second
one
they're still actually in questions
although we have moved into evading to
debate uh
admittedly but um i think we should just
move on from it i mean the officers
explained it
it's not satisfactory i don't think two
members but we are where we are
okay um right well
if there are no other questions from
members of the cabinet uh
councillor mclaren as the ward member do
you do you have anything you want
to ask um i mean obviously
for holbrook academy this is a good day
and for the young people who are going
to be educated there
[Music]
you know that is brilliant
i can understand councillor davis's
concerns and
but at this moment as councillor arthur
said
we're looking at this as a development
of a school
and education and so as a ward member i
supported that
thank you thank you council mclaren okay
um well we've had questions um does
anyone want to
proceed it any further in the debate or
or should we move straight to the vote i
think we've probably
exhausted the issues through through the
questions
happy to go to vote council arthur
just before you go to the vote can i
just say thank you very much to joe
for coming in we anticipated that um it
might be quite useful to have her here
to answer some
some detail and specific questions so
thank you very much joe
and if i could also just say thank you
to christine and the team who pulled all
of this stuff together
you may or may not know but christine's
um not that well at the moment so she
couldn't come in this afternoon
um she would have been here um but she
can't be here um
so in her absence just a thanks if tom
can pass that on our thanks to
um to the civil team for putting all of
the papers together for us again
thank you and tom didn't have to answer
any questions on sale
but thank you very much that's great
thank you okay then we'll move to uh
to the vote
separately
okay members so what we'll do is the
first vote
is for bid 2101
which is preston as detailed in
recommendation 3.1 of the report
i will start that one for you now
preston sorry
thank you members chair that vote is
eight four which is unanimous
so now start the second vote which is
for bid
b2014
which is holbrook and we will then move
on to a third vote after this
for recommendation 3.2
thank you members chair that's six votes
four and
two votes against so that vote is
carried
and then the third vote members is for
recommendation
3.2 as detailed in the report and that
is now in progress
council osborne have you voted
oh okay that hasn't come through can i
just take your vote verbally please
thank you thank you chair that's eight
votes for which is unanimous
thank you all right okay sorry
did was the first one for preston was
eight zero was it i don't i
don't know if you mentioned it it wasn't
thanks sorry thank you yes
that's right okay well um as i mentioned
earlier
um what was item 16 on your report
we're now going to cover now as it's no
longer
a confidential item so this is paper
bca21.5
spend against the climate change and
biodiversity earmarked reserve
and i'll ask the cabinet member for the
environment to introduce this report
council malvisi
thank you very much chair
just bear with me while i
find all my bits
right this covers the the work that we
have to do
in order to achieve um an understanding
of the biodiversity that we have in our
district
and it covers the mapping work that we
need to do
in july 2020 you recognize that the loss
of natural habitat was greatly impacting
on our wildlife the combination
is impacting on our climate change
in order to effectively manage this we
need to understand and enhance the
wildlife corridors that exist
but also where we need to create new
ones
suffolk biodiversity information service
have offered one thousand pounds seed
funding to support this work
in addition they'll undertake initial
network mapping as a pilot
part of the current remit to support
both baba and mid-suffolk district
councils
and the mapping will cover public realm
sites local nature reserves
and county wildlife sites
and the anticipated mapping costs based
on a joint proposal by
sbis and suffolk wildlife trust
are 12 250 and a breakdown is shown in
the table
in table two of the report once we have
accurate mapping information
it will enable us to increase our
understanding of the district's
biodiversity resources
by updating the county wildlife site
register
with a condition assessment it will
evaluate ecological assets within the
public realm
and opportunities for enhancement
initiate a pilot mapping scheme to
consider how sites with biodiversity
value
link into the wider ecological network
surrounding
the districts
i recommend that you
please grant the funding
thank you councillor may i have a second
to please
counselor mccraw okay does
anyone from the cabinet have any
questions on on this report
all seems to be fairly straightforward
and um i know we've we've all had a a
good
chance to to look at the contents and
and understand what we're trying to do
with these two
specific projects here um as councilor
malvis he said it's it's essential that
we do have
um a good understanding of uh
our biodiversity and also our tree cover
um
and and uh these these the mapping work
and survey here
will will provide that and will put us
in a good position moving forward
um does anyone have anything they wish
to
add counselor arty
thank you it's it's um a question about
this
um about the the tree canopy survey
and i'm not quite sure um
what areas are being covered because at
one point in the report i think it talks
about
um some um the suffolk wildlife trust
survey work and then there's this
this satellite imaging um which
appears to be able to identify
which trees are where
just simply by the satellite image
so i presume that's district wide isn't
it
yes it is councillorathe
does anyone have anything else they they
wish to add um
i just got one tiny tiny um
uh point i just noted and that's in
paragraph 4.4 and 4.9
uh the first one refers to appendix b
and the second one refers to appendix c
um they should actually be dependencies
a and b respectively not b and c
but um that's a minor issue and i think
we can get that corrected
that would be great um but apart from
that
um the the funding as as listed here
it's um these are
reasonable and we do have the
uh the reserve that's set aside and this
funding comes from that reserve so
um exactly the sort of thing that the
reserves
uh the reserve was set up to to provide
so um
we're all happy to move to the vote
castle crawl just wanted to point out
that it's i think it's significant that
we'll have outputs from the tree canopy
survey
as soon as september of this year i
think that speed is something that
you know has been overdue and i know
it's been discussed for many years
so very very much in favor
it's much easier to assess the canopy if
you can see the canopy yes that's true
easy to identify the species isn't it
okay we'll move to the vote now thank
you
thank you chair members you may need to
scroll down slightly on your mod gov
app to see this one it is now in
progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous
thank you thank you right we'll move on
then to
the the next item which is paper bca216
um again uh further spend against the
climate change and biodiversity in
market reserve
this time for water filtration and i'll
ask
malvisi to introduce this report
thank you very much chair um i'm very
pleased to bring this to
to cabinet the purpose of the report is
to get
is to get your approval to draw down
from the climate change and biodiversity
dedicated earmarked reserve
to install what's called a backwash pool
water cleaning system
at kingfisher leisure center this will
recover waste heat
and recycle water water is a valuable
resource
that is quite scarce currently the
leisure center uses a standard sand
filtration system which requires
cleaning on a regular basis
done by a process called back washing
the system uses a lot of water
and is highly energy inefficient
the spend of 24 900 comprises
twenty one point six thousand from
earmarked reserves
and three thousand from suffolk climate
change partnership
this will give the leisure centre a new
pool water backwash cleaning system
using electro coagulation
the system significantly reduces water
consumption
by reusing waste water but also reduces
energy consumption and carbon emissions
by reducing the need to heat pool
top up water so you get a saving on
energy and water the new system will
deliver the following benefits it will
reduce the annual co2 emissions
from between 6.4 and 8.6 tons per annum
it will reduce pool energy consumption
between 35
200 and 46 900 kilowatts
per annum reduce water consumption
between 1500 and 2000
meter cubed per annum demonstrate a
practical
corporate carbon reduction strategy to
the uk leisure industry and it
contributes towards
a carbon neutral building
and yet again it makes baber a leader
not a follower thank you very much chair
thank you councillor may have a second
to please counselor arthi
any questions from anyone counselor
arthi
yeah it's kind of a bit of a question
you always go question one debate but
it's a kind of a little bit of each
isn't it
sometimes so firstly um
i feel a bit for councillor malveezy um
it was a couple of months ago she had to
get a head around
hydro hydrogenated vegetable oil and
hydro treated vegetable oil
again to do with reducing our carbon
emissions
in that particular circumstance the
change that we were proposing was
actually more expensive
for us as a council but of course it was
far underway
the biggest contributor to our carbon
emissions
now i think we come to the the second
largest
single contributor to our carbon
emissions which is
our swimming pools and um the
interesting thing about this
i think is that not only um do we
address
carbon emissions but we also actually um
have the potential here to make a saving
and as councilor malvizi says it's not
only a saving in terms of
energy consumption it's also
saving in terms of water because i do
kind of understand these backwash
systems and to put it in simple terms
when you backwash a pool
you basically suck out a whole lot of
the water that you've heated
to swimming temperature um and put it
through the
filter backwards to rinse it out so it
all gets thrown away having heated it up
and it being perfectly clean water it
then just goes through the
through the filter backwards um and gets
thrown away
so there there are um real savings here
i don't know though if um
i mean they're not they're not huge but
they are quantifiable i think aren't
they council male vision
in terms of water and energy
yes they are canceller are they as you
say they're not huge
but gas and electricity costs would be
reduced between 1.1 percent
and to 1.5 which doesn't sound a lot
but then when you see their total
energy bills as a multiplier it is quite
a substantial saving
yes did you mute me did you
okay um yeah i think the other the other
part of the
the question really was about water
because we're talking
large volumes of water here with a pool
that size that's backwashed once or
twice a week
um we're we're talking about quite large
volumes i think
am i right that a thousand liters is is
a cubic meter is that right
yeah because i think there's reference
in the report to liters and to cubic
meters
um so a thousand liters i think is a
cubic meter
and weighs a ton so we're talking about
a lot of water here aren't we
to put it in layman terms it's about
the equivalent of 11 households
water consumption per annum
yeah actually it um as you stated
earlier that's on my vc between 1500 and
2000 cubic meters
do we know uh you quoted the percentages
for gas electricity usage
savings um what percentage of the total
water usage does that
2 000 cubic meters represent do we have
that as a percentage
no i don't have that percentage and i
don't have my calculator with me either
okay we'll we'll try and get another
exactly um outside yeah okay
uh cancer osborne and then councillor
davis
thank you mr chairman um i i think it's
a great way forward very innovative and
and demonstrates babies commitment to
climate change so i certainly support it
my question is i see from the report
that there's going to be quite a saving
in utilities and obviously that includes
the
saving on the water as well will baby
district council benefit from any of
these
savings in regards to the financial side
okay can cancel overseas do you have
it should do but i'll ask sharon if she
can step in
sorry councilman crore you want to come
in i've got it here it's table one on
page
uh 172. that's what i thought it was
somewhere um and the table one shows
a net annual saving of uh 5855 minimum
maximum saving 8 437 pounds
and for a capital expenditure of
21 650 that seems like a very decent
return
on that capital expenditure in terms of
an annual saving it
fundamentally could pay for itself in
as little as three years but certainly
would do so within four
so i mean and if any time you get a
return like
that on a capital investment you've got
to say yes please
the savings no they're not they are
savings that are provided according to
63 to uh babera district council
the responsibility for payments of both
the electricity and gas supply have been
transferred across
from our current leisure provider abby
croft to ourselves
so effectively this is a good deal
thank you council mcgraw castle davis
did you
yeah thank you um i think this is great
obviously
and i think it's important that every
decision we take
um goes towards our carbon neutral
target for 2013.
so in that respect and thank you for the
figures but in that respect could you
tell me
how much this will offset all the carbon
emissions being
for children being bussed in from all
different parts of
essex feeding stone needle market other
parts of ipswich
into the district it's a serious
question we've said we've got a carbon
neutral target
and yet we're making policies that
encourage
bus journeys from all sorts of areas to
the district
we clearly don't have that comparison at
the moment
but i'll tell you that later thank you
okay
any questions from anyone else
yeah councilmember yeah do you want to
say something i'll just add yes please
um to further enthuse the cabinet
it's it ticks off a lot of
boxes because it's going to reduce
costs for a leisure facility
which is bound to impact on the
residents of our community
as we come out of covid and start to
live
a full life so it takes a well-being box
it's going to reduce costs which
hopefully
the community will benefit from
yeah thank you um well again we've kind
of
veered into debate at the same time as
questions but does anyone
else wish to make any further comments
about this council osborne
thank you councillor for um identifying
that for me it shows i didn't read the
report properly i think so so i stand
corrected
um but what i will say is yeah you're
right there is a good saving for weber
and um in regards to the utilities so
i would hope that perhaps in a few
months time when we start to see the
benefits of these savings
we can look to reintroduce in the free
swimming again
at the kingfisher as we heard before and
take advantage of those savings that
we'll be getting from
from this investment thank you
yes i i quite agree and and but also
we've got to remember this uh
this is although this is something we're
we're financing we're investing with
installing it it is a trial we're
learning we'll be learning from this
um and and hopefully uh it will be the
success that we
we anticipate and it'll be something
that can be rolled out to other leisure
centres not not just to
hadley within baby but also um to
the other districts and boroughs in in
the county because i'm sure they're all
uh watching this and the suffolk climate
change partnership
has helped fund um this this project so
they'll all be interested in the outcome
council hull
to be fair you've just basically asked
my question which was uh if this is a
success then we'll be able to hopefully
sort of expand that and go to hadley and
um and
make even more savings but you pronounce
what you said so thank you okay
right uh council busby
yes this point about the responsibility
for payments of both electricity and gas
supply has been transferred across from
abbycroft to baby district council
okay we benefit from the savings of it
but how much i mean that's only the
savings presumably picking up
the rest of the costs when did that
happen does it reduce
has it reduced our contribution to abby
croft but
i don't recall that coming to us uh
chief executive is going to give an
answer for that i'm not saying if i talk
for long enough i'm conscious that cass
clements the assistant director will
probably email me an answer as well
because she's watching online um so i'm
conscious we had to
move it across as part of shifting to
green tariff
that's that's the extent of my knowledge
so it's part of an earlier decision
in order to ensure that we could access
green tariff
energies that whilst it sat with
avacroft wasn't possible but would be
possible if it was part of
a contract with us but i'm hoping in the
meantime cass will email me and answer
them in which case i'll come back
back in if i get one
see it worked thank you
there we go sorry um so yeah as arthur
said it was part of the green tariff
we have picked up the cost for those
utility bills but we will be looking to
mitigate that
with our partners through the management
fee
and lease arrangement in terms of
reclaiming that back
so faber won't be out of pocket
thank you sharon councilman crawl in
that case if we're going to mitigate it
are we also going to pass on the
mitigation of the savings
we're about to make with the backwash
scheme i know that's been
technical but could we just keep the
savings and just pass them on the costs
i don't know if we can but i'll take it
away
thank you okay um
interesting yeah okay then everyone um i
think then we're probably
ready to move to the vote on on this
item okay thanks
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress
uh
thank you that's eight votes for chair
thank you right moving on to the next
item um
there is no published paper for this
this is the suffolk waste and recycling
consistency and household and business
recycling consultation
and i'll ask the cabinet member for the
environment to introduce the item
thank you chair
i'm asking cabinet to
support the formula the formation of a
cross-party working group
consisting of myself
and a member from
the opposition i think that we're
looking for
four people on baba and four people
on mid suffolk
the group needs to be cons constituted
to consider the issues raised in the
consultation document for a response
to be submitted by the assistant
director for environment
and commercial partnerships under her
delegated powers
there is a link to
the consistency consultation site
which includes the documents below
now i don't know that anybody wants to
take a note of the web link
um right now but i can give it
afterwards
in december 2018 the government
published its 25-year environmental plan
the resource and waste strategy better
known as rose
this strategy forms part of the
environment built due for its third
reading in parliament
which we hope will be the autumn
the waste section of the plan has three
main elements
consistency in collections extended
producer responsibility
and the implementation of a deposit
return
scheme the underlying principles of the
strategy included in the elements above
are to achieve a 65 percent recycling
rate
and to ensure that the polluter pays and
that we
all generate less waste
the plan is for the implementation of
the strategy to start
during 2023
consistency and collections will have
significant and far-reaching
implications for the future of the waste
services local authorities provide to
their residents
and businesses proposals in this
consultation
include implementing the following
weekly food waste collections curbside
collections of glass increasing the
types of materials we collect
in our recycling collections and
changes to the garden waste collections
naturally we will continue to work
together
with all the other suffolk councils
through the suffolk waste partnership
on considering the implications included
in the consultation
and formulating a response however
with such far-reaching implications for
the services
that we as a district council provide
we felt it crucial that we set up this
working group
to consider the constitution and
formulation of a response
on behalf of baber
we've got lots of time to do it in we've
got till the 4th
of july to submit our responses
a provisional slot therefore is booked
for the first group meeting
this week on the 10th which is thursday
thank you mr chairman
thank you thank you councillor um may i
have a second for this
please counselor davis does anyone have
any questions
counselor uh castle busby when we
discussed this before i
raised the concern that we won't be
including in that working group
people that might be adversely affected
by the changes in the policy such as
single parent families or families with
a large number of children
people who live in flats etc what have
we done are we going to include somebody
from perhaps our tenants forum
uh on this working group is there
anything other than councillors on it
that's on my vc i have to say that
question hasn't arisen because
everything's happened so quickly
the information regarding this came
fairly recently i think the suffolk
waste partnership
have had a a meeting and discussed
a bit of it and we're trying to get the
working group together
to progress because we've only got till
the fourth of july
yeah the the the um the consultation
periods are very
very short um the the two other
consultations on the deposit return
scheme and the
extended producer responsibility uh
southwest partnership has has already
provided those because they had to be in
by the fourth of june
but this is the third consultation on on
collection consistency
and but we don't have time we just got
to focus on this and
and as as councillors and get our
response in
um and coordinated with um the rest of
our partners in the county
as soon as possible council arthur you
probably got more well yeah i mean the
the the point is that the people we need
a response from
the people that do the collecting really
which is us um
so i mean all the tenants do is like any
other household you could have a
householder group
um but i don't quite see the advantage
of that because they don't collect it
they put it out they present it for us
so i mean i think it's quite interesting
that the government have finally come
round to look at consistency
it's 22 years ago now
that the authorities in suffolk got
together
to try and deliver a proper strategy
with consistent collection across
suffolk
because we identified that as people
moved from one area to another
they were confused by whether they
needed a wheeled bin a metal bin a
series of black plastic bags whether
they could recycle dry recyclables
whether they could recycle garden waste
all that sort of stuff so we we set a
strategy
in 2001 i think our strategy was
published
and we achieved complete consistency um
there's a little bit of a difference in
bin lid colors i think between mid
suffolk and the rest
but other than that we we got
consistency um
across the whole of suffolk so it is
really really important
um you know the other problem we've got
now is
is of course while everything consistent
in suffolk people don't move within
their county boundaries they move
to other administrative authorities
so you only have to go across into essex
and you find that there's a completely
different series of
recyclable products that you can present
and in a completely different way
so you know while we've relied on on
paper banks bottle banks and things
a lot of other authorities haven't we've
made it on dry recyclables um
and a lot of other authorities were slow
to catch up on that
and then you've got the whole issue of
food waste as well and whether that has
to be collected or not
by all authorities and in all areas
so i think it's quite important um and i
think it's quite important for us to
respond as a collection authority
um i i don't want to disagree with um
council busby but i i don't think
there's a whole lot of point in bringing
the world and their dogs
into the conversation it's an open
consultation so if people feel strongly
enough about it um
they can respond especially i presume
towards things like packaging and stuff
like that
which are the things that present
households with with the problem
so um so yeah i'm fully supportive of
councillor malvis's proposal for a small
working group
um to to put some sort of response
together and as she said the suffolk
waste partnership are responding um to
all of the elements
of the consultations as well
thank you council arthi does anyone know
the councilor
mccraw and then councillor buzzfeed then
councillor osborne i just wanted to ask
if the prospective members of both
councils have been lined up given that
you're on a
a clock well we've got councillor
malvisi
and councillor arthi um
and we'll need somebody from the lib dem
group um so if councillor busby could
could discuss that with his
group leader and then after this meeting
um assuming we um agree to this and
then we'll contact lee jameson
and asking for a green representative
uh council blasphemy you were next to
the council osborne
i'm glad to see it's going to be a very
diverse group
for middle-aged white pensioners
sorry clive we don't have much choice do
we
i'm not here look it
it's all a good clive talking about the
color of the bins i mean it seems to be
the least important part of it
it's what people think they're going to
need collecting
if we we talked about reducing the
frequency collection of the black bin or
the whatever it is
being the residual bin because we're
taking food waste out of it well
that doesn't necessarily reduce the
amount of
stuff that's in that bin for some
families if you've got
young children the chucking in nappies
nappies a day
you'll soon fill up your black bill and
to have that lying around for an extra
week or two weeks
because four white middle-aged
pensioners decided that they didn't need
their black bins collected quite so
frequently
um it's not right that's why i think you
need a diverse
diverse group but if we can't do that
because of time then i think we should
ask the tenants forum to
to put forward uh a response you say
that anybody can respond well i didn't
know that was
i mean we weren't going to be asked for
this
okay uh councilmember it is an
interesting point perhaps we could um
in the next day or so see what um
look at the feasibility of that but i
don't think we can make any promises at
this stage
counselor osborne did you want to say
anything yeah thank you mr chairman yeah
on that point i think we do need to
involve our tenants i think they'll have
a lot to say on this particular
aspect we do have problems on some of
our developments with the collection of
waste
and i think it would it would help and
it would empower them if they feel that
had a voice
in how we move forward on this however i
am conscious of the fact that we are
limited for time
but there's no reason why the corporate
manager of
tenant services couldn't set up a tenant
board meeting
for them to be given the information and
they to feed
into the group that's meeting at dates
to respond to the consultation
but i think i think yeah i think
councillor busby's absolutely right we
should be involved in
the tenants council hulk
i disagree i think that this is about
all our residents not just our tenants
and i think it's our residents that are
the key to this
and as i spoke before when we have a
small briefing on this
what we need to ensure is we get a
policy in place that our residents will
buy into
because we if we don't we're going to
have a disaster
if there's a change in collection or a
change in how they separate their
rubbish then it needs to be bought in
with our residents not just our tenants
so
i would stress it's all our residents
not just tenants
council macro did you well
is our being elected as councillors not
part is this not part of our job as
councillors to make responses on behalf
of the council
um and cabinet can't take the lead in
there where else
could it happen i think we can all
get some feedback from residents either
of our parish councils or or
other routes into to residents within
our particular awards and
um and feedback information and views
to the working group but uh ultimately
it has to be the working group that
um puts forward our response but um
sourcing its information from as
wide a range of uh people as it can
in in the time available
councilman obviously just a
thank you chair just to point out that
the consultation is available online
so residents can elect us
members of the community can go online
i will circulate that information
to cabinet okay thank you
right well if there's nothing else uh
council arti
yeah and i suppose i've got to say
something else in response to what dave
has said
we we really we really
don't need to um to have all different
users of the service come in to tell us
what they put in their bins
we do regular bin analysis we know
exactly what's being presented we know
what we have to sort out that's in the
blue bin recycling that shouldn't be
there
that gets rejected we know what goes
into the energy from waste plant we do
regular bin analysis
we're not unaware of
the number of nappies that go in and i
don't think that
um dave ought to make the assumption
that it's only young families that
use things like that he said ho ho ho
you get older middle aged people don't
know about these sorts of things
well i've got to tell you that one of
the heaviest bins that the bin lifter
failed to pick up
was actually stuffed full of some very
very large nappies
because when people get old and they're
being cared for at home
and there's more and more people that
are cared for at home now
um i can assure you that they have they
they present
much more in the way of that type of
waste
than a family with a couple of little
children
thank you let's move to the vote shall
we
thank you
members that vote is now in progress
thank you chair that's eight votes for
that's you nellis
thank you right we'll move on to the
next item now
um this uh
following consultation just before the
meeting this item doesn't have to be
a confidential item although there is
one confidential element to it
namely appendix a which is a viability
assessment
but i'm proposing that we discuss as
much of it in open forum as
we can because um it is something that's
going to be of
particular interest to people i think
particularly those who live in hadley
um so it's item 15 um paper bca217 the
hadley
1871 roadside commercial workspace
development
and i'll invite the cabinet member for
economic growth to introduce this report
council holt just wait for the officer
just to
so we just wait for our changeover
you okay if you're honey let's start
[Music]
so
right i'll crack on and share that all
right right i'm very pleased to
introduce this paper i think it's
something
that shows the public how this council
is approaching employment and
we are lucky that we have
available to us a site that we are able
to take the initiative and intervene in
um this will be a direct and visible
investment by bay between being the
market failure for small work
space unit delivery where demand is
still out stripping availability and
we've had
mental reports in 2019 which clearly
show there's a lack of incubator space
we're actually conducting another mentor
report now to have a review of that
and it's clear that within the district
we do have this lack
of units for from sort of micro
startups and sole traders
it's something that's particularly an
issue
really in hadley and around sudbury as i
say it's district-wide but we're having
lots of houses built
and we do need employment and we need
the ability for these micro businesses
to grow and sole traders to move into
their own units etc
so i think this we're starting to take
the initiative on this
and we're starting to try and readdress
what is known as a shortage within the
district
this opportunity will enable us
to produce a retail store
and also it will make a difference in
that um
hadley in particular to say he's got a
housing development
quite close to this so there's an
increased population that
retail unit will enable that community
to have something very
close to them and it also supports our
investing hadley program
um the cost-benefit appraisals on the
three main scenarios including the
estimated
rate of return for the council has been
modeled with the report dependencies
and subject to reporting back to cabinet
in due course on final worked up
detailed proposals
the let retail cell b1 unit provides the
largest projected
rate of return of investment however
letting all the units provides an
ongoing rental stream for the council
recently the cabinet indicated that
should the investment be approved there
is a preference
to or at least in the short term retain
the units or the units for let and keep
the flexibility for a later freehold
disposal
if that was chosen with the
understanding that this option will
increase additional liabilities on the
council including potential voids
ongoing maintenance administration etc
there is an element of risk in ford
funding the surveys and investigations
ahead of the transfer of the plot to
labor
but undertaking this work now will mean
the scheme can progress
faster once this has taken place
initially this full ask would need to be
revenue funded by transformation funds
with 80 000 able to be returned and
capitalized once the scheme
progresses to creation of an asset
we can also confirm that there is a
hundred thousand pound of contingent
contingency modeled into these figures
to offset the cost
of surveys investigation and design work
towards a planning application
submission
this is additional to the construction
contingency allowance also costed in the
total development cost
the opportunities to further the
council's climate emergency ambitions
from a low carbon development
incorporating site micro regeneration
and electric charging facilities should
also be noted
i think as i said this i think shows the
public
that um we are in a position to do this
and we have the will to do it i think
it's something that we haven't done for
for a long time i can't remember and
whether officers can that
if we've actually done something similar
to this for quite some time
i would urge the my fellow members to
approve this and i would look
for a second to um for the
recommendation 3.13.2 3.3
3.4 and 3.5 because as i say i see this
is
weber leading the way in in a in an area
where
it's important that we have employment
land
turned into actual real units real
job opportunities um there's
a definite shortage we're very lucky
around ipswich and the fringe
to have some important building
employment land being turned into
sites going on but for the rest of the
district i see this is
a small but significant step in the
right direction
in intervening in what is clearly a
market-led
issue and failure to bring these units
to fruition
thank you thank you councillor that
council possibly will use secondly
yeah thank you for that um yeah
i i agree it's a it's an exciting scheme
uh and a great opportunity that's
been presented to us it's it's not big
but it's still significant for hadley
and uh and it's great news for hadley
the the location is ideal
adjacent to the a1071 um
uh questions i've got one first actually
a quick one
from me in terms of the
the funding for the initial feasibility
work do we have any
uh business rates retention money left
over that we could uh
divert towards this
lee do you want to pick that up
so sorry um yeah we've looked at the
options there is
sufficient in the transformation fund
which we put bid in for
um and obviously with the objective of
80 percent of that being reimbursed
once the scheme progresses as a capital
scheme
um the business rate parts are
quite depleted at the moment in terms of
what has been allocated to specific
projects there may be an opportunity to
move some of the funds around which will
require further reporting but for the
purposes of this
report we've confirmed the finance team
that there is sufficient in the
transformation carry forward
to fund this initial hundred thousand
thanks lee thank you
customer crawl
recommendation 3.2 suggests that we
resolve our preference
as to which option of the three
scenarios
should be progressed and i think that's
probably going to be the key
to discuss this with i just wondered at
what point we'll be doing so
uh obviously it would be uh great if we
could do that without uh
going into the detail of of appendix a
um it it might well be possible
to be honest um uh because i think our
councillor halters
has already indicated um uh what
one way forward on on that i think in
terms of uh a preference
but um if we can pick that up in a bit
does anyone have any other questions on
on the report
councillorati yeah i don't think it
falls within the
confidential section because section 106
i think is a public public document
so the question really is about how we
come by this land i think in the report
it's
called acquired or transferred
in 2022 i'm guessing that there is
no cost associated with this land it
forms part of a
planning approval and i'm guessing that
if the developer has got anything to do
with
the wording or has had anything to do
with the wording
i'm guessing there's likely to be some
sort of a restriction on
on what we can or can't do with the land
uh yes so it was transferred as part of
a section 186
um proposal and yes it's restricted to
employment use
okay just to follow on from that then
there there is no restriction in any way
um on us
developing the site and selling on
no no the restriction is about not
building residential on the site
councillor davis
[Music]
would we be uh be eligible for lab
funding and lab support
um the lep kind of channel
national funding out um rather than have
their own funding
so we always keep an eye on that as we
did with the um
but getting the britain building fund
that we got for the solar carpools
um at the moment i don't think they have
any funding to put in this we did ask
them
uh some time ago in terms of uh
feasibility
um but they don't they're not really
putting money into stuff like this at
the moment
um and like i said most of the funding
they have is channeled through
uh larger government funds so we keep an
eye out for it i'm not sure it's gonna
quite fit with the time scale that we
want to move this forward
yeah okay thank you
okay um if the
question or would you want to move into
debate yet carson sorry i was going to
say if only we knew a commercial
investment property company that might
like to invest in it but
okay uh
i think we've we're we're done with
questions or is that a question or
move into debate question okay
councilman crawl
i just wanted to confirm that um the
figures provided which are not going to
go into um
include the cost of this liability study
yes so the um the figures that we're not
going to go into because of the
confidential section do
include that um it's probably worth
mentioning because i can mention this in
the public
uh section that of the three scenarios
um i think councillor holt pointed out
the scenario three is is um
is is not something that would attract a
commercial developer because it shows
a low rate of profit that means if you
build the scheme and sell it quickly
it doesn't make you a lot of money um
however
as he's also pointed out holding the
scheme gives a fairly robust
income over a long term period and a lot
of commercial developers don't look to
do that they look to sell it on
so we we have um we have looked at those
three scenarios
um but from a sort of commercial
developer point of view but the council
is in a slightly unique
position in that it can hold the acid if
it wishes
okay thanks um
so if we want to debate um
the various scenarios um appendix a has
got
in uh an outline of the scheme
it's also got the pros and cons of the
scenarios
um and it's got uh the breakdown of the
initial funding which um
we've already talked a bit about what we
probably can't debate in in open session
well i know we can't debate in an open
session
the actual numbers in the table um in
the viability appraisal but
um uh in terms of the pros and cons of
the scenarios and and
assessing which of those we we want to
give priority to
um and does anyone have any comments
they they wish to make on
on the three scenarios
council arthur is michael um
sorry council holt um going to give us
his
preference
because my preference would be to retain
and have an investment come in i i would
like to retain control over the units
so i would prefer
to see possibly option
three that's that's my preference
to being able to support this without
going into
part two so i would support that um it
seems to me that if we opt for
scenario three now um we can at any
time in the future change to option one
or two but if we opt for option one or
two now we can't revert to option three
in the future
that is true it does leave all of our
future options open i think
where he leaves the future options open
yeah i think we're in this for the
longer game
and to retain control over that site
in the short term i think is important
to us
we have total control and if we do need
to to sell on those users at any point
or
the whole site then we can do that um
it's potentially the riskier but
as i say we're here i believe to to do
this type of work with here to deliver
these type of units
we need to take the initiative on this
sort of thing and
um i think this gives a great
opportunity for us to do that
and to show what we are able to do if we
if we get the right
land i know we would sort of fall in our
lap to a certain extent
but um there's no reason we can't use
this sort of model
and go forward into other sites should
they come available
even in a larger scale unlike a
commercial
developer we're not in it for the profit
we're in it to deliver
workspace opportunities for people jobs
and um i think this is a a great scheme
yeah it has fallen into our lab and we
should take
use that to our advantage and i agree
it allows us to to have that longer term
support for for businesses but also
speaking with
the my finance portfolio hat on the idea
of a net annual
income um irrespective of the precise
number um over a long period is
is something that um we cannot really
turn down as
as a district and we do need to maximize
our income from
uh alternative streams we've had this
debate um
many times around cifco and the need for
that
now because it provides us with that
income to replace lost government
funding
business rates council tax together less
than
50 of our income and we have to have
these alternative income streams
and and this is is part of that
and um i think to retain and and to have
that
annual income over over the long term is
is is the way forward
councilman craw and the other thing
about
apart from retaining flexibility it
seems to me that
the one-off profits are not that
significant in
in comparison to the annual rental
surpluses
and the figures in any
breakdown would show that the rental
surplus is far more valuable
than a one-off profit here
agree castle busby
what happened to scenario 4
which is to sell the retail unit and
let the b1 units
which i would have thought was the one
that we was progressing
no that's he's looking at the opposite
in scenario one
you haven't got scenario for
i don't think that was one we ever
considered it seems to me the logical
one to do which is you sell the
the retail unit which is probably where
the greatest demand is
and then you let the beat the b1 units
that you want to keep control over
we did look at that early very early
before we did any detailed modelling
and that retailers
would retailers you've got two scenarios
they'd buy a site
and put their own building up or they'll
lease it it's unlikely they would take
something that we would lease
that we would build at least to them
that the kind of retailers were looking
at which is a food store retailer
um i mean it's something we can test as
we go along
um but the reality is um that wasn't
deemed from our in early discussions
with local agents that wasn't deemed to
be in
something that was attractive to the
market so we didn't pursue it as one of
the models
okay i thought we had somebody
potentially in mind for the
retailer from a leasehold point of view
but not from a we build it and sell it
freehold once built
that's why that's why option 2 looks at
selling the site rather than the
the completed building i think as far as
most retailers do go down the route of
leasing yeah um they certainly don't
purchase land
and only they tend to just lease a site
in my experience in a lifetime
detail that you always are looking not
to have
property and money tied up in property
you look for lease back arrangements you
can sell off
the properties very frequently you build
the big shed
and then you lease it or sell it off and
lease it back in a long term period
because you retain flexibility that way
and the other danger is if we did find
somebody
who purchased a property if we could is
that they could
literally go belly up and that property
could be left abandoned
so yeah i don't think option four is an
option
okay uh thank you does anyone else have
anything
um they wish to say before we move to
the vote
um looking at the recommendations then
we've got um we've considered the
business case and the options appraisal
um it seems that we are set aside to
proceed
um and so moving on to 3.2
our preference therefore is scenario 3
and then 3.3 to 3.5 as stated
okay and we'll vote on that basis then
okay thanks clay
thank you chair members the boat is
ready
just waiting for one voter
councillor melvisi are you able to vote
that's great thank you that's eight
votes for chair
great thank you very much right we have
one final item
which uh we will have to go into
confidential session for because it's to
prove the
confidential minutes from last time so
um before we do that we have to go
through the resolution to exclude the
public
um so to consider whether pursuant to
part one of schedule 12a of the local
government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item
it is likely that there would be
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against each item the
author of the report
uh proposed to be considered in part
early gender is set aside of the public
interest in maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
do i have a proposal kassarati
seconda malvisi
we'll just have a quick vote on that
then
uh
so
councillor melvisi i'm still yeah
okay thanks
shall i take your vote verbally or has
it gone through now
seven votes four chair one abstention
thank you thank you
you